[Music]
last season Cougar Town had an episode
where you had naked day the naked day
episode is this something that you think
would be a good idea for couples to be
naked around each other in real life no
because well first of all I'm the kind
of person that prefers only to go out
from dusk until late at night
I don't like brought in sunlight
overhead lighting no I wouldn't mind
showing my boobs maybe but I would never
be walking around naked during broad
daylight nothing well I think most
people would agree with you that they
don't want to be walking around town
completely naked but you're saying what
about an intimate situation we're with
you're with a loved one do you're not
comfortable being naked like naked day
and they make it weight talk if you a
vampire but everyone looks better at
night but I mean maybe it'd be good for
you guys you know I really would not not
for me I would not be good I shouldn't
be seen in the daytime or the nighttime
no I don't know I I'm not we're not a
naked household Michael there's not a
lot of what my son occasionally just
walks around with things hanging out but
he's like a perv on the subway but the
rest of us know we're not a naked
household but I do hear there are
households Andy your there's a lot of
nudity oh my god there isn't there has
not been a closed bathroom door in my
house for four years that's where we're
starting I'm saying what do you think
not a problem around our so so you're
saying do you think you speak for most
women when you say they don't want to be
seen naked
I think so I mean it's supposed to be
four it was the way it was written in
the show was so it would rekindle our
relationship and keep it sexy but I
don't think any I mean that's tough that
would be tough to be walking around
naked
yeah and men probably I think it would
be good for your you know you guys have
you looked at all the time nicer than
your perfect Courtney why are you
assuming things get worse when the
clothes come off maybe it all jumps up a
notch
no you were right you were nominated for
People's Choice Award that's very
exciting and I would think and Harry
Styles of One Direction tweeted his fans
that they should vote for you which I
thought was incredible this is one of
the most becoming one of the most
powerful people on the internet and he's
tweeting for you yeah Harry Styles
tweeted for me and so did ed Sheeran
now these are two huge pop stars I just
gotta say so much for social media
because if I can't win if people to join
award with those two tweeting for me
that was it guys I blew my wad I got
nothing so Harry Styles and it didn't
work he got everything he got he tweeted
so sweet to do it and so was Edie and
yet I managed to get Abama next year's a
nice really tough times
now you directed a film last year and I
would think one of the cool things about
directing is you get to pick your actors
yes you get to decide and how did that
go that's a kind of power that must be
fun so we're given from acting yourself
when you get to decide who's gonna be in
my project it is you know I you do got
to the people that you want the most and
I actually have I went out to UM it's
Jack Black and I'd seen him well it got
back to me that he couldn't do it he
thought it wasn't wise to do it because
there'd be too much sexual tension on
the set so whack said this I saw him at
a party and I came up to him and I put
my arm around him I said so I made the
film and you didn't do it I guess they'd
be too much sexual tension huh
and he's like laughed and I said you
know what you're so funny last time I
saw you the stand-up that you did you
were just so funny he's like really I
don't really think of myself as someone
who just stand up so much but hey hey
thanks I said yeah you know you did it
for the ebee event he's like well what
CBS said oh it's the charity come dude
you were there I mean II be it's
epidermolysis bullosa this charity I'm
involved with and he said yeah I got
some do a lot of stuff you know and I
said oh how is your wife did you have
the baby and he looked at me he goes you
think I'm Zach Galifianakis don't you
yes I do Jack Black I'm so sorry because
I'm such a huge fan and I did offer it
to sure a huge fan you just don't know
which one I'm such a great actor and I
was like no I'm so sorry I think you're
amazing
love Jennifer yeah you got out of it
then you did the right thing